essentially Glaxo has been breaking it
in in China sales were up about 20% last
year that's about four times faster than
their average emerging market and police
in China say in part it's because
they've been paying out bribes even
sometimes in the form of sexual favors
now the allegations are that executives
use travel agencies as conduits to
receive these bribes they say some
executives even took sexual favors and
that other drug makers transferred money
to the agency they say the bribes went
to government officials Hospital doctors
all daquiri favor and totally allegedly
nearly half a billion dollars misused
currently though for GSK executives
Chinese executives are being detained
let's listen to one of them explaining
to the Xinhua news agency how the cost
of these bribes eventually does get
passed on to the price of the drug to
continue in these businesses I think the
operation costs involved in the medicine
price accounts higher than other parts
after these days self-examination
because everything needs a cost such as
holding a meeting or conference and the
cost should be included into medicine
price so considering the operation cost
it accounts a little higher now in
response to these allegations and these
interviews blacksmiths client said it is
quote deeply concerned and disappointed
they said they're doing all third-party
agency relationships and of course it
says they will cooperate with the
Chinese authorities Wow glocks is not
the only company that has been caught up
in this sort of regulatory I don't know
drug now he's not from in China exactly
it does seem like a dragon there are
currently four multi national drug
makers who are facing probes against the
authorities we know that from a lawyer
at Clifford chance in Hong Kong who's
been speaking to these companies who are
seeking legal advice I mean I don't have
to tell you a couple weeks ago you had a
medical executive on the phone oh
generally Tarn chief stars who was being
held hostage I believe in China so we're
really seeing broadly and effort by
regulators to try to crackdown on
corruption I was speaking to Jeff Jonas
he's a portfolio manager over at Cabella
funds and he thinks this is in part an
attempt by the administration with a new
leadership now in place to
be shown is taking a tough stance on
corruption also though an attempt to
lower prices he says frankly the Chinese
prefer local ownership local hiring
local manufacturing